welcome to the 2021 American League
Championship Series presented by loan
Depot they're ready again early start in
these parts on a Saturday for game two
with the Astros up one game to nothing
he's not worried about pitch count but
they don't expect
a long effort tonight
from Luis Garcia the rookie right-hander
went 11-8 he led rookies with his 170
strikeouts
had at least six strikeouts and 17 of
his 29 starts this year so he's that
tight pitcher got a different look
s ripped down into the corner
will dig into second as that ball just
stops on the wall and an easy double to
start the day for Boston
this is a little floater shallow Center
and
caught with a diving grab one away
what a catch in Center by McCormick tell
you what this is not easy look how he
positions the glove he gets it turned
right at the bottom to get it in the
glove and face plants that is as good as
it gets
keeping his wrist from getting injured
that's what you worry about
and then schwarber's in no man's land
trying to anticipate that ball going to
drop but
you know Garcia appreciated it
three balls and a strike that's inside
and that will get Brent Strom out of the
Dugout to talk to his rookie
right-hander Red Sox th
ief hits it in the inner right back at
the walls on
Grand Slam J.D Martinez
and a fourth spot in the first inning
for the Red Sox in game two
again everyone forgot about that but as
a pitcher you know that's what you can't
allow to happen against a great
offensive team because the more Runners
that are on base the more stressed
pitches you have to make the harder it's
going to be to navigate through this
lineup
and you don't want to see guys in a cart
the Red Sox
taking his ride down the dugout
and a Grand Slam in the first inning
3-2 pitch
struck him out but
it started with a double extended by
walks to Devers and Verdugo
and then that
by J.D Martinez
Grand slammed
first inning game two for nothing Red
Sox Nate
Nathan
Nate Dogg evolving
you're gonna see a lot of grunting you
can see a lot of fastballs split fingers
curveballs sliders Cutters he's got it
all he's got five pitches he throws at
least 10 percent and he's a strike
throwing machine Greg went one for four
last night floats one for a hit
jammed a bit but muscled it out into
shallow left between Bogart's Endeavors
that's in the center and [ __ ] puts it
away
a hit a man left after one in game two
four nothing on the strength of a
Martinez Grand Slam
I think Zach Greinke better put his
spikes on
this is going to be potentially a long
day for that Bullpen of the Houston
Astros
now there could be an injury situation
Maldonado went out and talked to Garcia
and then Carlos Correa joined the
meeting
certainly looks like he's being talked
out of something so he's gone
this is the last thing Dusty Baker
wanted although the off day the travel
day tomorrow
Garcia knocked out or injured
after facing one batter in the second
and it's odorizzy who's getting loose
the Red Sox have loaded him up twice
four nothing but a good result
under the pitch swings and drives one
deep to right field if it's fair it's
gone it is
Fair a grand slam the Red Sox have hit
their second grand slam of the game and
it's eight nothing first time that has
ever happened in postseason history
if one team has hit multiple grand slams
in the same game
and it's happened in the first two
innings remember when I said every
postseason you see something hasn't
happened before well we just saw it just
saw it here in a very confident
offensive machine that Boston has going
and a cart driven Fury here comes a 2-1
pitch to pique Hernandez how about
another
real
Hernandez with his third home run of
this ALCS it's nine to nothing and the
personal Hit Parade continues for the
first year Boston Red Sox
believable
he's got 15 hits in the last five games
over the postseason that is the most
ever in a five game Span in postseason
history and he's just adding to it
Tucker takes his time he'll get into the
box now
this one in the left it is off the wall
off the bat of Kyle Tucker and one runs
gonna score it's a 9-1 game Tucker gets
his first hit of this ALCS
that's into right field it is a fair
ball two runs are gonna score it's a 9-3
game here in the fourth
and Minute Maid Park is officially back
alive
Alvarez gets a base hit through the
right side and that's it the veteran
right-hander adavino coming in all those
delays and a strong effort by Nathan
eovaldi who leaves with his team up by
six Runner Alvarez will go 3-2 pitch
a little floater into Center base hit
Alvarez will go to third first and third
two out the payoff pitch swing ground
ball left side Rafi gets a good hop
throws on the Move in time and they
strand too that sucks get out of the jam
in the bottom of the sixth inning and we
go to the seventh the Astros fans
looking for something to get excited
about again got excited and the fourth
got excited last inning but Adam
ottavino got out of it here's Garrett
Whitlock
this one to the right side tough play
Arroyo oh got it
what a play by Christian Arroyo to end
the inning Wade to his left spun around
and a one-hot strike
to get Bradley
High Fly ball to left this ball is at
the wall and gone
guriel second in the game first home run
of the series and it's nine to four
should end it or will it fly out back at
the track at the wall wow straight away
center field Castro
two home runs in the inning and this
is a nine to five ball game Frazier
takes over top of the order
four Run game now two out bases empty in
altube if nothing else he could bring up
Brantley who could
yeah a chance to extend his hitting
streak Here Comes High Fly ball into
left back at the wall this game's over
Altuve ends it as he just got under it
and arise smile on the face of brazier
who gets the final out
last night four hours seven minutes
tonight four hours eight minutes
nine five is the final Vivaldi the
winner
and the Ricky Luis Garcia takes the loss
of ultra organic Seltzer as real as it
tastes